(intense electronic music)
- So, you may ask,
what's that title about?
Well, when you are
asked for a title early,
sometimes you don't know
what you're gonna say.
(audience laughing)
So, I figured I could say anything and
what I was thinking
about was Ramon y Cajal
and what he would have thought beyond
his great gift of seeing
things with the Golgi technique
that were actually hiding
in a forest of complexity.
That lead him to speculate
and make predictions that
we are still following
in Neurobiology today
about how things actually connect.
If he were alive today,
he would be in wonderment,
if you like, regarding all
of the scales of details
that we can now describe with
different kinds of
microscopies and labels.
He would probably be, as I think
this conference is considering,
amazed at the gaps.
So, where are we limited
with regard to filling
gaps across, either the spatial scales,
all the way from macromolecules to organs,
to the temporal scales?
So, today, I'm gonna tell
you a little bit about
filling a few gaps all
the way out to Life Spans.
Two projects about dendritic spines
and about lifelong memories.
But, I can't do this without giving you
a little background on techniques.
At The National Center
that Jennifer mentioned,
we use really two techniques
to do electron microscopy across scales.
One is Serial Section Electron
Tomography where we take
thick sections, map them to get the best
X, Y and Z resolution.
We look at systems that
can be manipulated,
so here a vestibular hair
cell is moving around,
that's what it's doing.
The top is rocking and
it's changing the output.
Or we use a method that was
pioneered by Winfried Denk
called Serial Block Face Imaging.
You'll see an alternative of
this from Hal Hess shortly,
where you can put a microtome
inside of a scanning EM
and just automatically record
image after image after image.
Kinda like taking a look
at a loaf of bread as you
keep slicing it, and get
a reconstruction with modern methods.
If you selectively stain in a cell.
As was done by these colleagues.
This was a sample we imaged
when we first got this
going about ten years ago.
That's the endoplasmic reticulum
in the mitotic spindle.
If the endoplasmic reticulum
is stained, in this case,
with horseradish peroxidase,
you can then pick out,
these are mitochondria.
Those are lysosomes.
Wait til you see the ER,
and this cell's just in the
early stages of dividing.
So that's all the ER.
So how do you find that
stuff hiding in plain sight?
First, unashamed pitch, we push
this technology quite a bit.
While Harold has pushed the technology
he's gonna tell you about.
We've been pushing this to
higher and higher resolution
and bringing stains in, as
you see here, so that we can
genetically mark components
in the context of this method.
We pushed it, so that you
can look quite easily,
at structures like the golgi
apparatus, mitochondria ER.
But we've done that through the benefit
of a long collaboration
with Roger Tsien, from
about the time Roger came to UCSD.
Even before the fluorescent
proteins, but then with
families of proteins,
coming up with ways of
marking genetically for EM.
Then ultimately with Alice Ting,
APEX, which is a small peroxidase.
Now, that was preceded by activity trying
something called Photooxidation.
Using a reactive oxygen generating probe.
Something as simple as Eosin,
to generate reactive oxygen
and capture diaminobenzidine,
which then can be reacted
with osmium tetroxide or
ruthenium tetroxide to give
you electron density in locations.
At the scale of molecules,
we can see receptors marked
quite clearly with this method.
Here's an example, getting
us into spines now.
Eric Bushong, who's here in the audience.
When he was a graduate
student in the lab, now he's
a senior scientist in the
group, tried out using
phalloidin, which binds to actin.
In this case with fluorescein,
but also with eosin.
We had it specially
conjugated, to give us a way
of doing actin by EM.
At that time, Francis Crick
had postulated, 1982, that,
"Do spines twitch?"
You can look this up,
it's a beautiful little
theoretical paper, which was
Francis' best thing being
a theoretician.
So these are all dendritic
spines marked by actin
in a confocal microscope.
The cell, that's a Purkinje
cell was also injected,
just to see it with a red dye.
At that time, our tomography
was best done with
massive microscopes.
Here's a person for size reference.
We could punch through with these
very high energy electrons,
three million volts,
through samples as thick as ten microns.
Kind of a light microscopic sample,
but you can see inside.
This is from a Fragile X
animal model, and you can see
how tortured, or variable, the spines are.
That's a hallmark of that
disease, in animal models
or humans.
Then if you switch to the Eosin
phalloidin, do more or less
the same thing.
That's the light microscopy.
Actin looks like it's all over.
It's not actually.
It's concentrated in the
spines and if you punch
through it, this is not a
tomogram, it's just a projection,
the spines are full with this
flocculent material that's actin.
It's not just filaments, it's
like we know in cells now,
a gel.
Actually forms dodecahedral plates.
So, fast forward to today,
we continue to develop these
techniques and the math, and Rick Lawrence
is a Mathematician, Sebastian
Phan, who I believe is here,
is a Polymer Physicist,
we developed software
and methods and automated
these microscopes,
so that we take as many as
a thousand or two-thousand
images of the same object.
By tilting the sample, rotating
it, kind of like having
a thousand drones in
this room simultaneously
taking pictures of you.
Then you have a super sampling,
so this solves to some
extent, what Daniels
said is the Z-Problem.
What you just saw play,
was one of these volumes.
I'll show you another one,
but if you extract the
dendritic spine from that volume,
that's what it looks like.
After you use some fancy
tools to follow the actin.
So that's the post-synaptic density.
This is a little finger-like process.
Probably this guy was trying to extend.
But this is just a surfacing of the actin.
Here is a more recent one
with something called the
Direct Detector, which we
invented at the center.
Here's the spine, head, neck,
the shaft of the dendrite.
These are actin polymers.
The little balls you
see are actin monomers.
Here, you can even see, if
you are close the to front,
membrane proteins in the membrane.
Then this is extracellular matrix.
Perhaps the perineuronal
net, that I'll talk about in
a moment.
What you can see actually
connects from the extracellular
space, through proteins in the membrane,
on into the cytoskeleton.
That's the second part of the talk.
If you look at this as a volume.
Just one slide, you can
see how rich this is and
how we extracted with
the right algorithms,
which you saw on the previous slide.
So this is what we do today,
at even higher resolution
than this, to match up
the molecular details that
are coming from structural biology.
Then to begin with different
cadence of experiments
to look at what changes during
sleep, wakefulness, time
scales that we can actually
stop action quite easily.
So with colleagues in Munich
and in Stockholm, we developed
methods to extract this kind
of information in large scale.
This is just an example
of how this is done,
slice by slice, and you
can begin to study these
and consistency between
spines in different regions,
or as was published in
Science recently by a group
collaborating with us.
How this changes when you sleep or awake.
Spines shrink by 20% when you sleep.
More adventuresomely, we're
saying okay, if we know
it's actin, or the majority
of what's there is actin.
What does it look like if
you substitute for the center
lines that we defined, for
the actin that you saw in that
previous colorful spine
spinning, actually actin?
Does that tell us
anything about the charge
and the crowding?
So this is taking actin,
replacing all the threads.
This is actin from the PDB.
Why do we do that?
Because the actin is highly
charged, very acidic,
and this leads us to
predict that the actin
creates an ion biding matrix,
a gel, and it's actually
the sol-gel changes that
may be driving a lot of the
physiology that's interesting.
That's a speculation.
Moving on, back to that
extracellular matrix,
in a short amount of time,
I thought I'd try and
squeeze in, what I think
is one of the most exciting
projects, kind of a leave from Roger.
This is what he and I,
and he was most excited
about when he died.
Projects now being led by
Varda Lev-Ram, who is here.
Having to do with life-long
memories, and Martin Hetzer,
who is also involved, because
this techniques overlap.
Roger's hypothesis is this,
you can look it up, it's in the
paper postulating that very
long-term memories might
be stored in a pattern of holes
in the extracellular matrix.
The idea being, if the
extracellular matrix holds
state and the more dynamic
things, like Daniel talked about
and you'll hear more about.
Know about the state of that
part of the brain, then those
things that turn over will
come back or form those
parts of cells, guided by
the extracellular matrix.
Kind of like the extracellular
matrix is the stone
that's chiseled in, that
gives a durable state
for the brain.
So that was Roger's idea,
that this extracellular matrix
would be edited by
MetalloProteinases, synapses formed,
synapses come to a shape
by activity or size.
Predicted that the synaptic proteins,
pre- and post-synaptic
would have short half-lives,
relative to the extracellular matrix.
So how do you test that?
How do you play with that?
Well, sorry, this is just
a little bit more about the
Perineuronal Net, which
had been described by Cajal
and others.
This is what it looks
like in light microscopy
with wisteria floribunda
as a fluorescent stain.
And this is some of the
molecules that are known to
be associated with it.
So you can use proteomics,
and look at that.
You can stain it, sorry,
I got ahead of myself,
You can stain this, the
same way that it was done
by light microscopy, by
doing a peroxidase reaction
to mark that material in
the extracellular space.
You can reconstruct it by
the methods that I showed
you, to see what it looks like.
The synapses are in these holes.
And then the question is,
"Does it stay around?"
What Varda did, following a
protocol that Martin Hetzer
had first done, was create
animals that are 100%
nitrogen 15.
You're otherwise nitrogen 14,
so this is kind of the most
expensive and heroic
pulse-chase experiment.
You can see the paradigm here.
What is it, eight hundred
dollars a kilo, for the food,
something like that?
So these experiments, for
the food, could be a hundred
thousand dollars for a
colony of sufficient size.
Then at the right point, after
let's say, a six month or
18-month chase, with the normal nitrogen.
You sacrifice animals from
the colony, grind up there
brains, do proteomics.
Then you are able to ask,
synaptic proteins have short
half lives.
Those molecules that I said
are part of the extracellular
matrix at six-months, still 30% of them.
At 18 months, they're
decreasing, but some of them
are quite significantly more persistent
than those constituents that
everybody's excited about
in synaptic plasticity,
which do turn over.
This is supportive of Roger's hypothesis.
Can we image N15, N14, so
then we went after tricks
that are done more in
geology, or in astrophysics,
looking at meteorites, or whatever.
Something that was taught
to me by a colleague,
Victoria Orphan, at Cal Tech,
working on some samples from
the ocean.
This is a machine that uses a
cesium-beam, knocks out atoms
secondary ions.
Runs em down something like
a mass spec column and then,
point-by-point, you get a
collection of masses for
as many as seven different atoms.
You can make a map.
So, one of the things we
tried, Nick's post-doctoral
advisor, Jack McMahan,
so this goes back a way,
postulated and then proved,
that agrin, a molecule that's
secreted into the
extracellular matrix guides
synapse formation for the
neuromuscular synapse.
We said, well, we have
intercostal muscles from these
mice, what do the end plates look like?
Do we see a signal from this
method that I just showed you.
Yes, so that would be predicted.
Here it shows you can do this.
We went from there, to ask,
in these samples, from the
mice that Varda grew.
What about this stuff?
This extracellular matrix, is it old?
Here you see, doing the same
sorta thing on those samples.
That in deed, it is. Okay?
And this by the way is myelin.
Myelin turns out like you
saw maybe, if you were paying
attention the bottom.
Myelin basic protein, two
other myelin proteins are old.
So this is telling you,
if you look at the brain
after the majority of
proteins have turned over.
Six months, 18 months later,
what piece parts are left
behind.
And here, this is the stuff
that presumably is left behind.
Turns over very slowly,
and these terminals.
These boutons come in, plug
in, in between, so this is
how would you say, data that
is headed in the direction
I think, of strongly
supporting Roger's postulate.
All of this is unpublished,
but I think it's exciting.
It's the product of, I think,
great thinking by many investigators,
great colleagues, great
collaborators, generous support.
This is the cast of characters,
some of whom are here,
and I think with that,
maybe I might end it early.
(laughter and applause)